hey guys and welcome to in two minutes
now it's kind of a serious one this week
as who all obviously shocked and
saddened by the death of beloved
nintendo president satoru iwata earlier
this month mr. water broke new ground
and led the company to new heights with
the phenomenally successful wii and DS
consoles and took a major gamble on the
wii u while conversations are still
ongoing as to who will become the new
head of the company jenya Takeda and
Shigeru Miyamoto have taken charge of
Nintendo until a replacement is found
gamasutra and games industry job babes
have both contacted industry analysts to
get their perspective on who will take
up the mantle of Nintendo CEO and while
even the likes of The Wall Street
Journal pitted the talus Matic creative
genius Miyamoto as the person to take
over quite a few analysts are unsure
whether that's actually a good idea but
why having the creator of Zelda starfox
and of course Mario lead Nintendo into a
bright colorful future seems on paper at
least to be a dream come true but it's
not that simple Nintendo is a
publicly-listed multi-billion dollar
corporation that operates across the
globe does it need a game's creator at
its head or does it need a shrewd
business brain Miyamoto is a visionary
and someone who has been central in the
design of many Nintendo systems a while
Nintendo is currently developing its
next console which is codenamed NX
Miyamoto has recently stated in
interviews that he's taking a step back
from hardware design to focus on games
such as Star Fox he said he won't be
actively participating and making key
decisions during n X's development so if
you could make the decision on where to
put Miyamoto where would you choose in
front of an endless stream of
spreadsheets in the company of investors
or would you put him on the studio floor
where he can actually work on games
maybe it would be better for the
lesser-known kenyatta kita to stand in
for Miyamoto Takeda manages hardware at
Nintendo and his accomplishments
throughout his 40-plus years at the
company speaks for itself Takeda was
responsible for the technology that
allowed us to save our gains onto NES
cartridges and he was a key architect of
the way he's also believed to be the
company's first-ever games designer such
experience
especially right now is invaluable to
Nintendo Takeda has been at the center
of Nintendo during it's dizzying highs
and and it's bleakest lows he is watched
the company reinvent itself over and
over again he joined before a water and
even before Miyamoto and few people in
the world will understand Nintendo's
institutional strengths and weaknesses
like he does this may just make him the
best candidate to take Nintendo into the
future a candidate who's possibly even
better than the world's greatest games
designer so while we don't know who mr.
Iwata successor is going to be just yet
mr. Takeda seems to be a good option and
if we think about the future of Nintendo
maura me Bo mobile games of DNA theme
park attractions and a new home console
this is all gonna need a strong mind to
make sure everything aligns anyway what
do you reckon do you agree do you
disagree do you not care let me know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games I'll see you
next week